députés qui ont moins de 30 ans on voit
que ce qui se passe à l'assemblée en
aucun cas transposable au sénat ce qui
est lié ce qu'ont expliqué au corps
électoral
effectivement le sénat qui a déjà une
image de chambre un peu vieillissante
poussiéreuse je pense que ça va pas
aller dans son sens il ya des
explications à ça mais c'est vrai que ça
donne une image d'une chambre qui peine
à se renouveler ne serait ce qu'en
termes d'âge par exemple ci n'est pas en
termes d'éthique et politiques locaux
très intéressant parce que l'inde est
l'un des enjeux ça va être pour le sénat
de montrer aussi qu'il a une capacité à
être l'acteur lui-même de son
renouvellement
et s'il ya un point sur lequel emmanuel
macron va sans aucun doute venir
à un moment donné ça serait dire aux
sénateurs bon ben d'accord j'ai j'ai
perdu les élections sénatoriales mais
regardez vous n'incarnez pas
suffisamment le renouvellement
donc ça va très important de voir
comment le sénat est très intéressant de
voir comment le sénat va ou pas employer
cette question parce que cette question
à un moment donné va lui être posées la
réforme rapidement qui vont être mises
en oeuvre
oui je je trouve alors ce qui vient des
dix est très juste c'est à dire que le
sénat va devoir faire montre d'une
capacité d'une volonté de réformes en
même temps je trouve que sur ce terrain
là on fait un procès un peu injuste au
sénat parce qu'en fait on lui reproche
de ne pas être à l'identique de
l'assemblée mais la logique même du
bicamérisme c'est d'avoir deux chambres
est d'avoir deux chambres qui
correspondent à deux représentations
différentes du pays et dont dire que
finalement c'est parce que ce sont de
grands électeurs qui désigne les
sénateurs qu'on a cette sociologie
particulière c'est un peu faire le
procès de nos élus locaux qui pourtant
sont nos élus eux-mêmes et de mon point
de vue si on avait deux chambres
exactement identiques ou un peu clown
finalement ça mettrait en cause
d'intérêts du bicamérisme d'autant que
les candidats ont fait campagne
justement sur cet aspect leur expérience
par rapport à des députés qu'on a jugé
nominatio n'a jamais dit c'est à dire
que être parlementaire c'est un métier
c'est un métier qui s'apprend et c'est
un métier qui se prépare en tout cas
historiquement à l'assemblée nationale
on avait beaucoup parcours militant
vous montiez les l'échelle militante peu
à peu vous appreniez ce qu'était la
politique et un jour on vous faisait
assez confiance pour vous présenter aux
élections législatives
ça ça a été un peu court circuiter ce
qui explique les relative grande
différence aujourd'hui entre l'assemblée
nationale présenté le sénat alors
qu'avant avant les législatives de cette
année
la différence d'âge était assez faible
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
au sénat vous avez ce parcours militant
mais il est plus rare vous avez plutôt
un parcours un cursus honorum au sein
des collectivités territoriales où vous
passez d'un mandat local à l'autre et
peu à peu et bien vous faites un réseau
de l'interconnaissance vos grands
électeurs vous font confiance et vous ai
dit au sénat
et ça au sénat ça ne peut pas réellement
changé et la république en marche a
également payé ce cette ignorance ou cet
amateurisme
vous ne pouvez pas envoyer un sénateur
putatif sur le terrain qui ne connaît
pas ces grands électeurs et espérer
qu'il soit élu donc pour le sénat à -2
bouleversé son mode de scrutin
ce sera difficile de le rajeunir avant
d'aborder l aspect réforme
constitutionnelle on continue les
réactions à ces résultats aux élections
sénatoriales avec vous mickaël szames s
de tags françois noël buffet oui on va
aborder justement sa question
institutionnelle question importante car
ce matin le porte parole du gouvernement
christophe castaner a laissé entendre
que emmanuel macron et est ouvert sur la
question du référendum à ce que ça veut
dire que pour vous vous êtes fermé sur
la question de voter ces lois
institutionnels pas du tout le présent
la pluie qui est ouvert et le sénat est
également ouvert et la majorité
sénatoriale fera des propositions et
sera dans un débat responsable avec la
volonté de trouver des solutions
à l'exception d'un point qui est un
point dur pour nous que le non cumul des
mandats dans le temps
là les choses sont très fermes de notre
côté et sur tous les autres sujets il ya
matière à discuter on espère bien que le
président l'a public entendra aussi la
voix du sénat et les propositions qui
sont les nôtres là aujourd'hui vous
laisser une porte ouverte donc sur la
réforme par exemple du csm les dose de
proportionnelle
nos cumul des mandats sauf le non cumul
dans le temps là bien entendu c'est une
porte grande ouverte aujourd'hui c'est
une main tendue que vous faites au
gouvernement
mais c'est d'abord la conception call
sénat de son rôle qui est de s'opposer
quand cela sera nécessaire mais qui est
d'être responsable de faire avancer les
choses
quand toute mention que c'est utile pour
les français et pour la france c'est
dans cette réforme constitutionnelle il
y à des sujets sur lequel nous sommes
ouverts à la discussion le sénat fera
des propositions et donc on espère bien
que le gouvernement accueillera
favorablement ces propositions et puis
que l'on puisse aboutir alors de mots
quand même sur les résultats
renouvellement du sénat
de nombreux nouveaux sénateurs vous en
réjouissez vous aussi bien sûr c'est
important pour l'institution il ya un
renouveau il ya surtout une majorité qui
est conforté la majorité elle est
recentré et conforter c'est un point
extrêmement positif pour nous on voit
bien qu'à rappeler qu'en marché est en
difficulté mais parti socialiste se
maintient à peu près en tous les cas
donc c'est pour nous une chance très
importante c'est pour le sénat a un rôle
très particulier dans nos institutions
il devient une voix de deux débats de
discussions voire d'opposition avec le
gouvernement mais ils représentent une
force importante et c'est très bien
comme ça
merci beaucoup aux prochains de l'alu
federer répondu à nos questions vous
voyez qu'il ya quelques sénateurs
présents dans cette salle des
conférences ou ainsi marie noëlle
lienemann pour le parti socialiste qui a
été réduit hier qu'il donnait une
interview puis le président me du groupe
l'est républicain que l'on voit ici
sur ces images vous que l'on vous
propose bruno retailleau en discussion
avec des sénateurs
on se retrouve tout à l'heure delphine
viens d'entendre françois noël buffet
parler du sénat comme une force hier
gérard larcher employer le mot de
contre-pouvoir alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire être un contre-pouvoir est ce
que c'est réellement le rôle du sénat
d'être un contre-pouvoir alors le sénat
c'est d'abord une composante d'un
pouvoir c'est-à-dire du pouvoir
législatif ce qui est vrai c'est que là
encore l'idée du bicamérisme c'est
d'avoir deux regards en quelque sorte
sur chacun des taxes chacune d'aidé
cision qui est prise par voie
législative et que de ce point de vue là
on a voulu modérée c'est tout souvent
d'ailleurs ce qu'on dit c'est que les
députés sont réputés impétueux peut-être
parce que plus jeune en tout cas
clairement plus politisé et que de
l'autre côté on a une chambre qui est
toujours présenté comme une chambre de
réflexion
ça n'a pas été rappelé tout à l'heure
parce que c'est une évidence c'est aussi
une chambre qui à renouveler
progressivement par moitié là nous
raisonnons sur le sénat issu du scrutin
d'hier comme si c'était une élection
comparable à celle des législatives mais
ça n'est que la moitié des sénateurs qui
a été renouvelé et donc c'est vrai que
que politiquement le président du sénat
qui plus est candidat à sa réélection
effectivement cherche à montrer la
dimension contre-pouvoir est logique
juridiquement constitutionnellement je
dirais que le rôle de modération à
l'intérieur du pouvoir législatif est
plus conforme semble-t-il à l'adn
institutionnel de la vème république
dans un mall morel comment comprenez
vous ces termes de contre pouvoir si
vous voulez
le sénat est l'héritier d'une tradition
de chambres aristocratiques qui en fait
faisait exister une seconde chambre pour
faire pièce à la fois au roi et en même
temps une chambre populaire donc il ya
cette idée de ne pas pouvoir réformer le
pays sans l'aval de cette chambre
héritière des chambres aristocratiques
et dans tous les pays beecham héros on
peut avoir des modes de composition de
la seconde chambre différents en
revanche on a toujours ça on a toujours
cette idée d'une chambre qui peut faire
blocage donc je tout à fait d'accord
c'est un pouvoir de modération c'est
également un pouvoir qui doit pouvoir
faire blocage à certains moments
notamment en termes de révision
constitutionnelle et c'est ce qui était
bien évoqué dans votre sujet donc là il
va falloir voir comment va vouloir
exercer
ce pouvoir comment le sénat va vouloir
exercer ce pouvoir et ça va dépendre
pour beaucoup à la fois du groupe l'est
républicain et en même temps de la
capacité du gouvernement de modérer
peut-être sa réforme constitutionnelle
qui lui même est assez radical notamment
pour le sénat et qui ne trouvera
probablement pas de majorité ici sachant
qu'en effet si le président de la
république veut réviser la constitution
d'abord cette majorité des trois
cinquièmes n'est pas suffisante il lui
faut l'aval du sénat
et ça il est peu probable qu'ils aient
ou alors il peut réviser la constitution
directement par référendum ce qui est
légalement discutable avec l'article 11
mais dans ce cas là il prend un risque
un double risque très important
premièrement d'apparaître très
autoritaire ce qui lui a déjà posé
quelques problèmes de communication par
le passé on se souvient de la sphère de
vivier au mois de juillet et
deuxièmement et bien tout bêtement de
voir son acte qui pourrait paraître
autoritaire refusé ce qui le mettrait
dans une situation politique assez
compliqué et intérêts non je pense pas
d'abord dans l'expression qu'on
contre-pouvoir c'est bien sûr kim
dimension politique pas seulement
institutionnels c'est aussi la
déclaration de gérard gachet s'est aussi
de deux d'envoyer le message à emmanuel
macron qui est dire il faudra compter
avec nous il faudra compter sur nous et
et on est dans ce moment très
particulière la vie politique où chacun
est en train de retrouver sa place ou de
trouver de poser sa place et personne ne
va voir le rôle du vilain celui qui
empêche emmanuel macron de porter des
projets qui serait bon pour la france
donc tout le monde est plutôt sur l'idée
il faut soutenir comme des projets vont
dans la bonne direction
il faut être constructif il faut être
dans le dialogue
donc tout le monde aujourd'hui dit ça
mais tout le monde n'y met pas
exactement les mêmes mots les mêmes
réalités à l'intérieur d'une même
formation politique et donc gérard
larcher ceci adressé à ses troupes il
est candidat à sa succession je crois on
peut dire sans trop de risques voilà
sans trop de risques mais
il faut aussi que le président du sénat
montre au groupe le plus important au
cedac il est certes dans le dialogue
dans le consensus mais qu'il est en même
temps dans il est membre des
républicains donc on est dans ce moment
très particulier
alors après ce que la réforme
constitutionnelle est par terre ça je
pense pas parce que de toute façon pour
le moment on ne sait pas très bien
quelle serait sait quelles seraient ses
contours et on va être à nouveau dense
dans ce jeu certains vont dire bah oui
si ça va dans telle direction fait sinon
s'opposera justement on parle
toute la difficulté pour le groupe et
l'air ici à se positionner vis-à-vis de
l'exécutif
bruno retailleau justement président du
groupe plr au sénat est à votre micro
mécano mais vous allez lui poser la
question pour nous absolument position
difficile pour le président que vous
êtes du groupe
lr aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des manuels
macro où tout est clarifié dans les
choses sont très claires je pense que le
revers quand marche a enregistré pour
les sénatoriales nous donne une mission
une double mission
il faut que le soldat incarne un
équilibre en termes de pouvoir c'est à
dire qu emmanuel macron ne peut pas
prétendre mettre main basse sur toutes
les institutions de la république
donc nous seront garants d'un équilibre
des pouvoirs avec une opposition qui
sera une opposition exigeante et
intelligente on améliorera les choses
mais quand c'est pas bon pour les
français nous le diront et puis nous
sommes la voix des territoires et je
pense que l'exécutif a eu beaucoup de
maladresse vis-à-vis notamment des élus
locaux pas seulement financières en
termes de considération
quand on dit que les locaux servent à
rien qui en a beaucoup trop alors que
90% vous le savez très bien sont
bénévoles
alors que finalement tout ce qui n'est
pas résolu par paris leur tombe sur les
bras il faut avoir un peu de
considération envers ceux qui se
dévouent pour la république entendu le
mot respect il reçoit de la part du
président du sénat est ce que vous
diriez que emmanuel macron a manqué de
respect il a menti en tout cas de
considération quand on dit ah trop
d'élus locaux ça veut dire qu'ils sont
inutiles
or vous savez moi j'ai fait campagne
j'ai vu beaucoup d'élus locaux et ils
sont au bord du découragement beaucoup
nous ont dit écoutez nous on va déposer
le paquetage parce que c'est tellement
difficile
si en plus on nous manque de
considération alors à quoi sert ton je
pense que la france a besoin de plus de
civisme
or les élus locaux qui sont encore une
fois ceux qui se dévouent pour les
autres représentent ce civisme et on n'a
pas besoin de moins de civisme et sur
les institutions on est français c'est
qu'il nous disait que la porte était
ouverte sauf sur un point un point clé
est ce que vous confirmez que la porte
est ouverte
je confirme que on a toujours une porte
ouverte ici mais qu' il n'y aura pas non
plus de chèque en blanc voilà et quand
je dis que nous serons et que nous
sommes une opposition intelligente
exigeante
il n'est pas question d'avaliser
n'importe quoi qui par exemple
déshabillerait les territoires qui sont
les plus pauvres en démographie la
france périphérique existe il y à une
france au delà du périphérique parisien
et par conséquent il faut en tenir
compte
titre personnel vous serez donc candidat
à la présidence du groupe l'est
républicain mercredi prochain absolument
je le serai merci beaucoup
renault retail vous d'être intervenu en
direct sur l'antenne de public sénat
d'autres sénateurs évidemment à suivre
de la fina tout à l'heure mickaël bruno
retailleau qui vient donc vient de
confirmer qu'il serait candidat à sa
réélection à la tête du groupe l'est
républicain
caroline vigo on vient d'entendre
justement bruno retailleau sur cette
opposition exigeante et intelligente est
ce que vous pensez bien qu'il y aura un
terrain d'entente entre l'exécutif et le
sénat pour trouver un contenu qui
satisfasse
finalement les parlementaires dans cette
réforme constitutionnelle je pense que
politiquement ça sera compliqué pour
tout le monde ça sera compliqué pour
emmanuel macron de convaincre la droite
de voter cette cette réforme
constitutionnelle et ça sera aussi
compliqué pour la droite de dire non on
n'en veut pas alors qu' il ya des
mesures assez populaire dans cette
réforme constitutionnelle parmi laquelle
la baisse du nombre de parlementaires
ça sera compliqué de monter lui bruno
retailleau qui pose ses conditions pas
question est bien que cette réforme
cette réforme pardon se fasse au
détriment des territoires les plus
pauvres en démographie et quand on se
souvient de la révision
constitutionnelle lancée par françois
hollande au congrès de versailles au
lendemain des attentats du 13 novembre
s'en est suivi des mois de 2,6 co drame
de rebondissements de part et d'autre
pour finalement se solder sur un
renoncement est donc un échec alors même
que à la base
droite et gauche étaient plutôt d'accord
sur le principe de la déchéance de
nationalité
le problème de ces révisions
constitutionnelles c'est que il ya
beaucoup de politique là dedans et que
est ce que la droite sera prête à faire
ce cadeau à emmanuel macron us
qu'emmanuel mâcon saura convaincre la
droite c'est compliqué d'y répondre pour
l'instant à la levade moi je suis moins
pessimiste sur le sort de la révision en
tant que tel pourquoi parce que la
logique même une révision de la
constitution c'est ça allait me trouvais
très naïve c'est qu'à priori justement
on n'appréhende pas avec des a priori
politique mais que l'on cherche à avoir
le meilleur équilibre institutionnel
possible alors c'est vrai que si l'on
présente à chaque fois les choses comme
un cadeau fait au président est un
cadeau fait au sénat j'allais dire que
la surinterprétation qu'on donne du
processus peut conduire parfois ce qui
est des blocages mais on a des exemples
même si le sénat a été majoritairement à
droite avec majoritairement une majorité
gouvernementale de droite depuis 1958 on
a des exemples de réformes qu'on pouvait
penser ne pas être spontanément en vogue
au sénat je pense par exemple à la
parité qui ont été adoptés sans que ce
soit un psychodrame politique donc je
pense qu' il peut y avoir des
discussions qui conduisent à ce que si
tout le monde estime que ces d'intérêt
général cette réforme soit adoptée
en revanche je ne pense pas qu emmanuel
macron puisse prendre le risque de
recourir à l'article 11 qui est là un
référendum
excluant complètement les parlementaires
c'est à dire qu'il s'agit pas juste de
savoir s'il voudrait ne pas avoir à
contrer le sénat il s'agit aussi de
savoir si non j'aimerais sa propre
majorité parlementaire
et j'ajoute que si ça a été fait en 1962
et de manière moins opérationnelle en
1969 c'était de gaulle c'était un autre
temps et je n'imagine pas aujourd'hui
qu'on puisse ainsi utilisé cette
procédure pour bien merci beaucoup anne
levade merci à vous caroline rigoureux
merci bruno cautrès merci benjamin morel
on continue à les réactions politiques à
ce scrutin avec vous savez rien projet
qu'à votre micro marie pierre de la
gontrie
elle vient d'être élue sénatrice
socialiste de paris cet amour absolument
bonjour marie pierre de la gontrie qui
toute nouvelle sénatrice a depuis hier
soir sénatrice de paris de paris c'était
triste socialiste dans quel état
d'esprit êtes-vous là vous arrivez tout
juste sénat c'est un mélange d'émotion
de fierté de
oui de de satisfaction y compris
politiques parce qu'à paris on a fait un
résultat pour la majorité municipale qui
est excellent et pour les socialistes
nous souhaitions avoir quatre sénateurs
élus et c'est le cas donc oui c'est
toujours un mélange personnel faut pas
se raconter d'histoires bien sûr qu'on
était muet
et puis une aventure d'ailleurs on est
venu aujourd'hui on est tous venus tous
ensemble parce que c'est toujours du
collectif la politique
enfin ça devrait l'être alors vous avez
déjà une longue carrière politique
derrière vous sur quels dossiers
comptez-vous vous investir au sein d'un
monsieur avocate de profession et j'ai
l'intention d'aller à la commission des
lois est de me préoccuper de toutes les
questions de libertés publiques au sens
large c'est-à-dire justice sécurité etc
et puis aussi comme j'ai été pendant 15
ans 1re vice-présidente de la région ile
de france la question des collectivités
locales donc
donc voilà donc j'attends avec
impatience ces sujets les deux sujets
méritent de manière générale beaucoup
d'attention et dans la période parfois
un petit peu de préoccupations
relisez votre liste a fait de très bons
scores à paris iv 4 sénateurs élus c'est
le signe de la renaissance du rebond du
parti socialiste au sénat
en tout cas c'est le signe que nous
sommes capables les socialistes d'être
unis dans une période on va pas non plus
raconté que tout est simple mais sur les
enjeux importants nous nous sommes
rassemblés et c'est aussi le signe à
paris avec anne hidalgo qui est maire de
paris nous avons au total huit sénateurs
sur 12 qui soutiennent la majorité
municipale ou qui en font partie
ce que c'est souvent des conseils de
paris donc tout ça et tout ça est bien
attention c'est allez on va dire c'est
une première marche
pour pouvoir reconstruire tout est
encore devant nous et de façon plus
générale comment analysez vous ces
résultats c'est un coup de semonce à
revers pour emmanuel macron je pense que
dès les responsables de la république en
marche ont tort d'essayer de limiter
l'analyse du résultat acquis et 1 qu'est
ce qu'on appelle une contre performance
en matière sportive au fait que oui mais
les élus municipaux
nous n'étions pas là à l'époque et état
c'est un raisonnement qui ne fonctionne
pas parce que lorsque emmanuel macron a
été élu président la république
et lorsque les députés ont été élus de
manière massive en marche
on aurait pu dire oui mais il y avait
pas de partie et il y avait une espèce
d'entousiasme d'appétit pour ce
mouvement dont personne ne savait
exactement ce qu'il était mais qui
attirait incontestablement donc
prétendre que c'est simplement parce
qu'il n'a pas d'élus municipaux
labellisé en marche qu'il n'y a pas de
sénateur ou plus de sénateurs je pense
que c'est un peu court
donc il faut attendre un petit peu
l'inquiétude des élus locaux
parce que la suppression des contrats
aidés ou ou la baisse des dotations
c'est quelque chose qui inquiète
évidemment mais élus locaux les
associations on l'a bien vu pendant la
campagne vous savez quand on quand on
discute avec des élus locaux et c'est
encore plus vrai quand on est élu de
départements qui ne soit pas aussi
urbain que paris des contrats aidés qui
disparaissent c'est souvent des
associations qui assurent une part de
service public va être obligé d'arrêter
têtards a donc donc bon c'est un petit
signe dallaire dommage qu'ils préservent
la république et laisser dire qu'il
n'était plus intéressé aux élections
allemandes qu'à l'élection sénatoriale
hier c'est pas bien merci beaucoup merci
marie pierre de la gontrie pour ses
premiers mots ses premières réactions
tant que toute nouvelle sénatrice de
farine merci beaucoup savaient rien on
va prendre à présent la direction de la
manche pour voir à les résultats de ce
département les équilibres ont été
respectés de sièges pour la droite et un
socialiste
mais le suspense a duré longtemps pour
départager notamment jean bizet et le
candidat la république en marche c'est
un reportage de fabien becker avec
olivier creuser
beau joueur jean-michel maj félicite son
adversaire socialiste le candidat de la
république en marche fini quatrièmes
dans la manche avec 14% des voix
il ne siègera pas au sénat je pense que
les si les listes
u10 modem et centre heller m avait pu
s'unir avait pu travailler ensemble je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y aura un
sénateur ou une sénatrice de plus des
unions ou essoufflement
pour philippe bas sénateurs et l'air
sortant qui conserve son siège
il s'agit ni plus ni moins de
l'éclatement de la bulle et l'air em le
rideau de fumée autour dans marche est
en train de se dissiper
est ce que les gens voient maintenant
c'est la réalité
les grands électeurs de la morge qui
représente toute la population de la
manche qui nous ont démocratiquement
choisies ont envoyé tout de même un
message qui est un message de réalisme
désunion au centre mais aussi à droite
puisque philippe bas affrontait un autre
sénateur et l'air absent lors de
l'annoncé des résultats jean bizet
semblait s'attendre cet après midi à une
défaite
ils sont finalement son siège à 13 après
une élection n'est jamais gagnée
d'avancé et surtout celle ci avec 18
listes d'une part et puis je dirais un
climat un petit peu délicat si vous
voulez bon mais me voilà davantage
rassurés l'émiettement des voix à droite
profite au candidat socialiste
jean-michel houlgate termine premier du
scrutin et succède ainsi à jean pierre
godefroy
pour lui le prochain combat à mener
s'inscrit sur le terrain du social
souhaitons la réussite de la france mais
à des conditions et il faut
véritablement que la question sociale
puisse se poser c'est vrai que à l'heure
actuelle il ya les incertitudes
notamment au niveau des lois travail
donc il ya des choses que nous n'aurions
pas nous nous n'avions encore été aux
affaires mis en place deux sénateurs et
l'air et un sénateur socialiste pour la
manche
comme lors de la précédente législature
les équilibres politiques n'auront donc
pas changé dans le département et
j'accueille mais l invité sur ce plateau
catherine progression bonjour sénatrice
à l'est républicain
duval demain vous avez été réélu
re merci d'être avec nous également sur
ce plateau eric bocquet bonjour au
sénateur communiste du nord également
réélu hier merci d'être avec nous
françois patriat bonjourbonjour
résidents du groupe la république en
marche ici au sénat on va bien sûr
commenté le mauvais score décevant
peut-être pour votre parti et puis rémi
féraud bonjour d'être sénateur
socialiste de paris
vous avez été élu hier pour la première
fois merci d'être avec nous et
j'accueille enfin hervé mort et vous
êtes sénateur il dit il c'est de leur
merci d'être avec nous première action
pour vous françois patriat puisqu'on
voit notamment par exemple à travers cet
exemple de la manche jean michel match
qui avait été investi par la république
en marche qui finalement n'arrivent pas
à percer comment on est presque 24
heures après ces scrutins comment
analysez vous justement c score décevant
ce revers pour le chef de l'état
bon vous avez remarqué qu'il ya
plusieurs sièges que nous avons manqué à
quelques voix je crois qu'il y a dix ou
douze sièges à moins de 50 voix donc ça
veut dire que n'ayant pas d'électeurs au
départ puisque aucun grands électeurs
ont été élus en marche
nous arrivons presque dans dix
départements supplémentaires à ce que
nous avons gagné aujourd'hui à être élu
ce qui est quand même à vous et vous et
une pas mauvaise performance est ce que
nous aurions pu mieux faire sans doute
certains or une contre-performance votre
cas vous avez moins des lieux
aujourd'hui que vous n'en aviez la
création du foyer on n'est pas les seuls
il est allé se lier d'autres groupes ici
qui en euros - le groupe l'est
républicain et le groupe centriste va
progresser mais tous les autres groupes
la grèce donc on n'est pas les seuls
donc pour tout bon ça pourrait être une
défaite aujourd'hui sauf que nous n'y
avait pas de chronique de victoire
annoncée
personne ne l'a jamais dit on l'avait
espéré pouvoir le faire progresser nous
ne progressons pas aujourd'hui nous
stagnons nous régressons même un peu
attendons attendant la semaine prochaine
pour connaître la composition des
groupes
on verra effectivement qui nous sommes à
égalité soudan m'a gagné je peux
considérer que nous aurions pu me faire
mais dans le même temps je pense que
c'est une deuxième page qui s'ouvre pour
le mouvement en marche
je tends des commentaires à peu
désobligeant que je ne relèverai pas ce
que je peux dire par ailleurs c'est que
la vraie élection sénatoriale pour en
marche et leur a lieu après les
élections municipales
aujourd'hui c'est un troisième taux de
l'élection municipale 2014 2015 2016
avec les cantonales et les régionales
qui a des produits que des grands
électeurs
appartenant soit au parti socialiste
soit au party les républicains soit
centriste quelques communistes il n'y
avait pas de grands électeurs
il n'y avait pas de groupe au sénat il y
a deux mois il y en a aujourd'hui il va
sans doute progressé malgré tout mais il
pèsera dans plus d'accord avec ce qu'il
vient de dire m françois patriat est ce
qu'il y a quand même néanmoins une
sanction des manuels macron dans ces
scrutins bas clairement je crois que
c'est pas polémiquer que je le dis dans
tous les contacts qu'on a eu dans ces
semaines et ces mois de campagne moi je
j'ai constaté que le nouvel exécutif a
réussi en moins de cent jours à se
mettre à dos tous les élus locaux taxe
d'habitation confirmation d'austérité
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
les contrats aidés ça grogne est très
sérieusement et ça s'est traduit dans
les yeux rougis serait une erreur de
contester cette sanction trois mois
après l'avènement d'un nouvel exécutif
en être là il y avait quand même eu les
pronostics un peu enthousiaste dans la
foulée de la majorité historique à
l'assemblée on parlait de 60 sénateurs
puis au milieu de l'été 40 50 et fin
août j'entends monsieur castadère parler
de 10 ça serait bien
le résultat aujourd'hui il est
sanctionné par les grands électeurs il
ya un message que vous auriez tort de
négliger
justement sur ce point on va écouter
longuet sénateur qui a été révélé hier
dans la meuse il était l invité de notre
matinale territoire d'un four on écoute
c'est la démonstration d'une faiblesse
du président de la république ça il est
en désaccord il n'a pas su établir de
lien avec les territoires de notre pays
c'est un homme des grandes
administrations des grands services
publics de l'état des grandes branques
des grandes métropoles moyenne des
petites villes du monde reut la ne sait
absolument pas senti qu'on brise par ce
président de la république et aero je
crois qu'il a un véritable effort de
compréhension des territoires le chef de
l'état ne comprend pas les territoires
écoutez je voudrais d'abord dire à
françois patriat que j'aime beaucoup que
la république en marche qui prétend
faire de la politique autrement et bien
faire la politique autrement c'est pas
faire comme on le fait sur tous les
plateaux télé depuis des décennies ne
pas reconnaître qu'on s'est pris un
échec pour ne pas dire une gamelle qui
dit parce que parce que moi je réagis
pas dit notre collègue parler de
d'estimations à plus 60 sièges
je crois même que que juste après les
législatives on sait que le groupe la
république en marche pourrait avoir 90
yens qui a dit faire après on est passé
à 2,60 après on est à 50 et aujourd'hui
on est en négatif et je suis je suis
étonné que françois patriat qui incarne
dans cette maison la république en
marche c'est à dire le nouveau monde
c'est à dire la politique autrement ne
dise pas oui c'est un échec
il nous explique que c'est un succès
donc je trouve que le nouveau monde
aujourd'hui il ressemble curieusement à
l'ancien monde pour pas dire à la
préhistoire
pour répondre à votre question surprise
la république c'est pas lui faire
offense que de dire qu'il ne connaît pas
la france profonde qu'il ne connaît pas
les territoires quand que sa première
fois qu'on a un président de la
république c'est même la première fois
qui n'a jamais été élu local et donc
forcément et on peut pas lui en vouloir
il lui manque cette cette connaissance
du terrain cette dimension qui est
nécessaire quand le présent la
république par rapport au territoire
et effectivement le le principal
adversaire de la république en marche
dans cette élection sénatoriale ça et
emmanuel macron parce que quand en
pleine période électorale
vous supprimez la réserve parlementaire
et que vous êtes anglais par là même les
territoires ruraux que vous supprimez
sans prévenir personne les contrats
aidés et que vous mettez un grand nombre
de communes ont dit qu'ils n'avaient
jamais voter il faut pas il faut pas
s'étonner
il faut pas s'étonner que la république
en marge dont on nous promettait un
triomphe au sénat soit en recul c'est
aussi simple que cela
avant de me mentir les urnes mais
supporte pas beaucoup quand même faut
pas mentir comme ça il ya des vérités
qui blesse vraiment le vieux monde passe
de la caricature maintenant dans le
mensonge
personne n'a jamais dit qu'il irait 90
sénateurs en marche 80 j'avais dit quand
nous avons près créé le groupe que nous
espérions pouvoir le doubler
plus doubler si nous pouvons progresser
ensuite ensuite
ensuite j'ai rectifié les chiffres au
coude ne retenons pas que la date du
match et un kit est dans la période
inactive ensuite
ramener le sénat simplement elle et
collectivités locales à une affaire de
réserve parlementaire à une affaire de
telle ou telle dotation le sénateur et
le sénat il est ici pour voter les lois
moi je parle du déficit de la france du
chômage demain des impôts
parlons là la république en marche elle
n'est pas élue elle pas lui simplement
pour gérer la réserve parlementaire ou
tel ou tel critère de collectivités
locales elle est la haute main et ça n'a
pas facilité la tête voudront le voir
notre part pour voter les grandes lois
que nous aurons à voter demain c'est à
dire est ce que demain on va empêcher
d'augmenter le déficit est ce qu'on va
diminuer les dépenses
est-ce qu'on va relancer l'emploi
saluant des latéraux et à 4 je ne m'a
pas encore entendu sur ce plateau rémi
féraud vous entrez ici au sénat la sq
avec sentiments justement de rentrer
dans l'ancien monde où le nouveau je
rentre au sénat et je n'ai pas
l'impression de représenter l'ancien
monde mais je suis un socialiste fidèle
et toujours été un militant de gauche et
je serai un sénateur socialiste engagé à
gauche on voit bien ici le débat sur le
rapport au chef de l'état est ce que
vous ferez dans l'opposition comme la
majorité sénatoriale de droite au delà
du rapport au chef de l'état emmanuel
macron le président de la république
c'est un rapport à la politique
gouvernementale
moi je me j'ai été élu on me situant
clairement dans l'opposition avec
l'associé la socialiste que je
conduisais à paris et qui a rencontré un
succès inattendu pour certains parce que
oui en dehors de nos qualités
personnelles il y à une inquiétude
notamment à gauche sur l'injustice
sociale des mesures qui sont annoncées
sur des domaines extrêmement importants
comme le logement la politique de la
ville les emplois aidés ça compte dans
les quartiers populaires j'ai vu comment
ces questions sont montés au cours des
dernières semaines et oui devions
beaucoup de l'iss dont beaucoup
d'adversaires mais la liste en marche
avait manquer de modestie
ces dernières semaines alors que il ya
une inquiétude et puis une volonté de
aussi de faire exister la gauche
le groupe socialiste d'ailleurs s'en
sort bien et bien mieux que les
hypothèses les plus optimistes même s'il
n'est pas en augmentation à catherine
procaccia en ce qui concerne la droite
on voit qu'elle sort ici renforcée de ce
scrutin
votre groupe l'est républicain va-t-il
échapper à la constitution d'un groupe
constructif selon vous je n'en sais rien
on verra
en tout cas constructif ou pas le groupe
l'est républicain et renforcer on est
pour l'instant plus de 150 155
comme le disait mon voisin on verra à la
constitution des groupes ce qui se passe
on au sénat il faut que dix personnes
pour constituer un groupe donc c'est pas
très compliqué de constituer un groupe
mais faut-il savoir à quoi sert d'avoir
un groupe si un groupe ça sert
uniquement avoir un nom et un président
c'est pas l'intérêt l'intérêt est de
voir quelle politique on veut mener en
tout cas par rapport aux républicains on
a toujours été très claire ce qui va
dans le bon sens on peut le voter ce qui
va dans le mauvais sens on ne votera pas
on a fait exactement de la même façon au
sénat sous la présidence hollande et un
certain nombre de textes sont passées
grâce à l'appui du sénat quand il était
bon on les a amélioré on a apporté notre
réflexion notre savoir faire
je trouve simplement que tout concentrer
dans les débats sur la république en
marche bas à la république en marche au
sénat c'est pas l'essentiel des forces
politiques
l'essentiel des forces politiques ce et
cce nous est donc effectivement parlons
un petit peu des forces politiques
plutôt que de trucs concentrer sur un
mouvement qui a peut-être eu un grand
succès il ya quelques mois mais dont on
ne connaît absolument pas l'avenir un
succès éphémère françois patriat
sans doute pas quoi qu'il se soit passé
hier
rien n'empêchera la marche en avant du
gouvernement pour appliquer les réformes
qu'il a décidé donc c'est avec beaucoup
de sérénité
j'entends par là de déséquilibre je
crois qu'il aura
un équilibre entre les mesures sociales
et les mesures économiques beaucoup de
procès d'intention qui ont été faits
j'entends parler des appels et autre
côté tu fais pas mais ce que je pensais
quel est l'intérêt du pays est-ce que
l'intérêt de payer aujourd'hui c'est que
le gouvernement échoue j'entends autour
de moi des gens qui disent c'est
éphémère le pied d'argile belle jouait
donc j ai le sentiment que des gens qui
aujourd'hui vivent leur revanche
parce qu'ils ont pris une large défaite
au mois de mai et au mois de juin sont
en train de jubiler parce qu'au sénat à
une élection qu'on connaît qu'on savait
prédestiné prédestiné on savait très
bien connue des municipales la droite
allait progresser c'était pas ça va très
bien c'était mécanique tout le monde le
dit vont vous espériez de droite se
déporte parce que les grands électeurs
c'est aussi des citoyens etc ces mêmes
citoyens qui ont été voter pour le
président la république
ces grands électeurs qui élit grands
électeurs qui ont été élus sur des
listes politiques appartiennent aux
états majors politiques et vote comme
les états majors politiques
et pour parer ce qu'on évoquait barrière
l'instant combien y at-il de conseillers
municipaux de paris qui avait été élu
sous l'étiquette en marche 0
il n'avait 0 mais plusieurs leur j'en
avais 0 donc donc il a fallu aller les
chercher des navets 0 donc on pouvait
pas espérer à paris aujourd'hui compte
tenu des lecteurs qui obéissent à leurs
d'état-major avoir une beaucoup plus
destinateur à paris peut-être deux
fadela rate le siège à 30 voix un des
deux bouquets et reebok et comment faire
justement pour ne pas apparaître comme
l'opposition frontale au chef de l'état
qui pourrait peut être aussi conduire à
son échec dans certaines réformes pour
lesquelles elle était plébiscité lors de
son élection
oui plébiscité son vrai projet il a été
adopté par quoi 17 18% de l'électorat
français et élu contre qui on sait au
second tour pour éviter le pire une
nouvelle fois voilà le socle politique
véritable monsieur mâcon c'est celui là
alors dire qu'après on a mandat pour
faire tout je pense qu'il faut être
beaucoup plus prudent que cela la
négation désir le beaucoup d'amis gaza
ni dire non mais politiquement soyez
beaucoup plus prudent que ça beaucoup
plus réservé et les premiers signaux
et à la france réduction de l'isf est ce
qu'il y avait urgence à réduire les sf
qui va et c'est un milliard aujourd'hui
ça rapporte et 5 milliard 3 le code du
travail
on y va billon a lancé j'ai c'est parti
et alors on peut pas s'étonner qu'il ait
lu trouble chez les élus et au delà de
l'ensemble de la population quand même
c'est la première fois que je vois qu'il
n'ya pas d'état de grâce au début d'un
quinquennat on est à trois mois après
l'élection du mois de juin
j'avais dit que non mais attendez il ya
quand même une situation faut regarder
les choses objectivement aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron on va parler du centre
puisque on donne la parole à toutes les
forces politiques
je voudrais vous proposer d'écouter
jacqueline gourault qui a été c'était la
seule ministre en campagne pour ces
sénatoriales a été élu hier elle était
notre invité ce matin on écoute le
centre est une vraie famille politique
en france
elle fait partie du paysage politique
depuis de longues années avec des
valeurs héritées notamment de la
résistance nous y sommes très attachés
hérité de chrétiennes et je crois que
les majorités se construisent à partir
de plusieurs familles politiques tout en
se respectant
c'est assez horrible ans parce que il y
à la droite en france et elle défend ses
valeurs elle et elle est respectable que
l'on laisse le centre vivre est avec eux
et que on le laisse sur ses valeurs et
sur ce qu'il a toujours dit ce qu'on dit
comment le centre va t-il faire entendre
sa voix notamment ici au sénat hervé
morin écoutez je pense que le centre va
pouvoir faire entendre sa voix dans les
meilleurs conditions puisque on a un
groupe qui progresse on va sans doute
dépassé les 50 membres
on est peut-être même le groupe qui
progresse le plus moi j'ai été élu
sénateur il ya tout juste neuf ans le
groupe centriste on était moins de 30
et aujourd'hui on est plus de 50 c'est
comme une progression dont on parle
assez peu dans les médias qui dans les
médias dit que le centre a progressé de
cette manière
en moins de dix ans donc je me réjouis
évidemment de ce résultat la voie des
stands sera différente
écoutez cydia
groupe au sénat c'est bien parce qu'on a
des choses différentes à porter que nos
amis du groupe l'est républicain
on est très clairement dans la majorité
sénatoriale
on est très clairement à soutenir gérard
larcher aussi bien ce qu'il a fait que
sa candidature demain si les candidats
ce qui semble être le cas
néanmoins on a nos spécificités notre
sensibilité et bien sûr on fera en sorte
qu'elles soient largement entendue
demain au sénat
il faut aller plus vers plus d'autonomie
écoutez on n'a jamais été des godillots
ça aussi ça m'amuse beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'entendre à peu près tout le monde dans
la classe politique d'hier à vannes où
on votera si c'est bien on votera pas si
c'est pas bien j'entends des gens qui
disent acquis qui l'ont jamais fait
jusqu'à présent c'est dans l'adn du
centre d'agir ainsi
moi quand j'ai été élue je les dis il ya
maintenant neuf ans c'était nicolas
sarkozy qui était président j'étais
censé être dans la majorité j'étais dans
la majorité mais à quantité texte
proposé par nicolas sarkozy que j'ai pas
voté ce qui n'a pas été vrai dans tous
les groupes de la majorité
et après sous françois hollande ça a été
la même chose quand tu fais des textes
il nous paraissait bien on les voter
quand il nous paraissait pas bien haut
niveau tu es pas donc je veux dire moi
je me réjouis de voir qu'aujourd'hui
cette pratique très pragmatique de la
vie parlementaire l'islate iv bien elle
est reprise par de nombreux groupes mais
chez les centristes cette pratique elles
datent pas du mois de mai dernier elle
est vraiment dans notre adn d'être
pragmatique et de juger sur pièce les
textes qui nous sont proposés rémi
féraud vous pourriez rejoint leur amour
est justement sur cette attitude
vis-à-vis
du chef de l'état des réformes qui vont
être soumises d'ici au parlement un
soutien au cas par cas en fonction des
textes
oui mais c'est vrai que ça peut ne rien
vouloir dire donc s'il s'agit de dire
par avance qu'on votera contre tous y
compris ce avec quoi on est d'accord
cette façon de faire de la politique
d'ailleurs il faut qu'elle change donc
oui si j'avais été sénateur j'aurais
voté pour le projet de loi de
moralisation politique il ya quelques
mois quelques semaines
en revanche je me situe clairement dans
l'opposition et je souhaite que le
groupe socialiste au sénat se situe
clairement dans l'opposition nous allons
en discuter cette semaine
est ce que ça vous laisse quand même un
petit peu d'espoir ce que vous entendez
sur ce plateau en ce qui concerne la
révision constitutionnelle certains ont
dit hier qu'elle était enterrée et
françois patriat
sans doute pas j'ai le sentiment que le
gouvernement le chef de l'état mme
mèneront à bien l'ensemble des réformes
sur lesquelles ils ont été élus parce
que j'entends aujourd'hui dire il faut
écouter le peuple il faut écouter la rue
du toujours match qu'il faut écouter
d'abord le peuple sait les élections
j'ai le peuple quand il s'exprime dans
les urnes
et c'est là la vraie voie démocratique
c'est pas celle de l'art est clair donc
le porteur d'eau l'islam donc s'il ya
des élections qui par quatre au bout à 4
tours ont légitimé le programmes des
manuels mâcon qui n'en change pas d'un
iota aujourd'hui parce qu'il l'a exprimé
etc de façon très claire et qu'il
applique aujourd'hui on va reprocher à
ce gouvernement d'appliquer le programme
pour lequel il a été élu quant au socle
17 18 je veux pas vous renvoyer au souk
du parti communiste aujourd'hui non pas
très important mais c'est un pur sang
neuf à lyon non d'accord n'auraient plus
me parlant des choses qui craint ce sont
des choses qui compte et pas de s'est
dit content d'un brûleur et un peu de
journée pour nous alors déjà moules se
dresse et j'ai même de l'amitié pour
vous mais quand je vous entends dire on
discute le socle du président le
président est élu avec 65 % des voix au
deuxième tour
je ne connais pas de pays démocratiques
et ne respectait pas la démocratie quand
tant de dire qu'il a le pied d'argile
aujourd'hui je pense que non seulement
il mène à bien les réformes qu'il entend
faire et qui va poursuivre et ce pays
qui a pris du retard qu'ils dépensent 10
% de plus d'argent public que tous les
pays européens qui a déficit de 2008
nokia chômage de masse vous voudriez
qu'on reste là vous les yeux d'un stylet
et réunionnais
non et ensuite les poissons de ligne je
crois que trois ans d'immobilisme
il n'est pas fait pour moi j'ai une
question très précise dans le projet de
mosquée 2018 qui va être présenté
bientôt
combien de milliards sont prévus au
remboursement de la dette
acquise par la france depuis 44 ans l'an
dernier on a remboursé 44,5 milliards
d'euros en intérêts aux marchés
financiers qui nous financent donc on
n'a pas commencé à rembourser le premier
euro de capital et ont narré en
emprunter l'an dernier 185 milliards ça
continue ou en êtes-vous sur cette
question vous voulez vos propositions
vous drx catherine procaccia mois jour
de vous entendre sur la révision
constitutionnelle certains délires
qu'elles étaient récompensés vous moi je
ne crois pas on n'est pas dans une
position dogmatique de dire on va
refuser une révision constitutionnelle
tout dépend ce qu'il ya dedans
en tout cas il est certain qu'au sénat
et je pense sur la plupart des vents le
fait de d'interdire à ce que des maires
se représente plus de trois fois alors
que c'est la population qui doit décider
si c'est des bons mer et qui veulent les
garder ou pas ça c'est quelque chose sur
lequel quasiment tout le monde va être
d'accord sur la diminution du nombre de
sénateurs en tout cas à droite ça
faisait partie aussi des projets qui
avaient été présentées je ne suis pas
persuadé qu'on soit opposé la révision
constitue une révision constitutionnelle
pourra se faire mais pas forcément celle
corps a décidé sans vouloir la modifier
d'un iota
le président de la république tout à
l'heure je vous entendais parler de
l'article ans je crois que l'article 11
et quand même une harman qui peu
dangereuse puisque on sait bien qu'en
règle générale les français ne répondent
pas à la question mais disent leur
mécontentement leur contentement par
rapport à la politique gouvernementale
avant de continuer l'analyse avec vous
on va tout de suite retrouvé au comptant
un chalmé qui nous attend allez le pour
un point complet sur tous les résultats
des hauts de france
bonjour delphine et je vous ai apporté
ici la une de la voix du nord qui
revient dans son édition de ce matin sur
ces élections sénatoriales avec à
l'intérieur à cet article sur l'élection
dans le département du nord en
particulier ou et bien
le journal titre sur les sénatoriales
des vainqueurs mais peu de monde pour
sauter de joie car c'est l'enseignement
dans ce département du nord où il y
avait onze sièges à pourvoir
les grands groupes comme les centristes
menés par valérie létard ou mais aussi
le ps de patrick kanner ou encore les
l'ère de marc philippe daubresse et bien
tous pouvaient espérer voir plusieurs
sièges au final ils n'en ont que deux
chacun sait le pcf et qui avait
également deux sièges et les
indépendants ainsi que en marche qui
rafle un siège qui sortait bien un peu
leur épingle du jeu dans le
pas-de-calais autre enseignement dans ce
département voisin et bien le fn n'aura
donc pas de nouveaux sénateurs à la
haute assemblée
c'était pourtant là l'un des seuls et
bien réservoir de grands électeurs et
qu'il y avait et bien non pas de
nouvelles et sénateurs pas de nouveaux
sénateurs fn est le deuxième
enseignement de ce scrutin dans le pas
de calais et bien pour jean marie
vanlerenberghe c'est une relative contre
performance puisque il ne voit qu'un
seul siège pour sa liste en marche
voilà donc pour les enseignements dans
ce deux départements qui disait 11 et
huit sénateurs hier dans le nord et dans
le pas de calais merci quentin très
rapidement un petit commentaire sur ce
qui s'est passé hier dans les eaux de
france satisfaction de voir votre groupe
renforcé que ces deux sénateurs
communistes et aussi pas de sénateur
front national qui était pourtant une
possibilité pour le parti frontiste
aidants naturels magnifiques images de
la place de l'adsl il au passage je veux
le souligner ici un peu de chauvinisme
oui bien sûr on est satisfait de ce
résultat parce que ce n'était pas écrit
d'avancé ce n'est pas qu'une question
d'arithmétique
c'est une question politique de fond on
a fait de la politique avec tous les
élus dans toutes les communes des tous
grandissement du nord et voilà il y a
dans le résultat il ya une partie de ce
travail de proximité et le travail dans
la durée également une confiance qui
s'est créée
patiemment et bien merci merci à tous
les cinq pour à l'analyse suite de nos
éditions spéciales sur public sénat la
journée
[Musique]